ce message nous demandent de rembourser
un emprunt qu'on a fait répondre de fer
qui accessoirement la banque la plus
dangereuse du royaume mais que les
mystères sont pas de mise
la sueur en bourse par jour là on n'a
plus un sou
bye bye le trône de fer et budget papier
toilette est serré ce possible falloir
retourner dans les douves
ont suivi les conseils stupide de
l'orbiteur c'est vrai emprunter de
l'argent aux banques et les plus
dangereux du monde c'était mon idée ne
pas les rembourser ça ils l'ont trouvé
tout seul mais fidèle compagnon ce qui
me journée très très difficile pour moi
alors je dois vous annoncer que malgré
tous nos efforts nous ne prendrons
jamais la tête du royaume
ok on a terminé
est-ce que je suis invité à manger de la
viande faisandée pourquoi pas leur trône
parce que la banque de faire nous à tout
prix on n'a plus rien donc soit on a une
sorcière soit on a un fils de dragon
je suis un vrac un vrai bordel avec des
papiers il n'y a pas de papier mais je
suis un fils de dragon les fils des
dragons ils ont les cheveux dorés
j'ai eu beaucoup de mariages entre nous
et les gens du sud c'est pas une preuve
ça ok une preuve voulez une preuve
supplie le demande a bûché trop théâtre
n'ont pas trop théâtral au théâtre à z
je demande un peu chier sinon je connais
une sorcière
bon les gens de la maison vous allez
nous faire un bûcher s'il vous plaît non
muselés et que tu touches avec pions il
a du sang de dragon il est censé
résister au feu mais moi je pense qu'il
va plutôt se crever la gueule
j'ai rien dit parce que j'adore les
activités en plein air vous vous prouver
à tous que je suis bien fils de dragon
je vais me jeter dans un bûcher de feu
à lui mais bon pour l'instant ça va
and all the bridge a brûlé des mois
attendez attendez pas ça va en fait
juste une petite sensation de brûlure
engendrée tous nos corps brûlés fait des
petites clientes attendaient et
attendait sous les petites cloques
qu'est ce qu'il ya on dirait comme des
écailles des écailles de drame
[Musique]
moi je comprends pas pourquoi ils ont
l'air surpris comme ça je sais pas et du
feu tu jets dans le feu tu meurs alors
on savait pas si c'était fils bragon ou
pas le fils dragon apparemment c'était
pas le filet des dragons
[Musique]
c'est ma première cérémonie funéraire
genre officiel j'étais super excité à
l'idée d'écrire le discours mais je sais
rien sur lui en fait fils de on ne sait
pas qui tu es mais la soupe de potiron
et pourtant tu es mort tu pensais que
brûler tu ne pourrais pas et bien brûlé
tué brûlé tu as
en même temps c'est du feu on te la mets
dit si tu étais encore là je te dirais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
geller la bonne nouvelle c'est que grâce
à élise que fils de dragon on peut avoir
le trône de fer
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que comme
c'est alice le fils de dragon celui chef
attend dé moi je passais ce jeu chômage
alors
l'eiu pas lisse des dragons
donc là je pus
[Musique]